I clearly understand what is taking
place and we all clearly understand why
all of that is taking place I cannot
share with you the Tactical views of our
military of our Warriors but as of today
we can see that the country which a
dozens times is bigger than we are
cannot occupy us cannot win in this
world and we understand that a bit more
and then we will be prevailing that is
why we are acting how we are acting
valuing availing lives
the hardest is well if Bachman
he had some military tactical mistake
for instance and people could be
surrounded then all the military know
what could happen
how we could create the situation for
people not to be captured now our people
are accomplishing a very important
Mission they are now in Bahama I will
not share where exactly but it witnesses
that Bahamut is not occupied by Russian
Federation as of today there are no two
or three interpretations of those words